قال رئيس الفرنسي مانويل ماكرون ان على
اوروبا ان تقلص ارتباطها بالولايات
المتحده
وتتجنب الدخول في مواجهه محتمله مع الصين
في قضيه تايوان واضاف ماكرون في مقابله
صحفيه ان ما وصفه بالخطر الكبير بالنسبه
لاوروبا هو ان تجد نفسها تنجر الى زمات
ليست ازماتها ما سيمنعها من بناء
استقلاليتها الاستراتيجيه
وحذر من ان الاسوا هو الاعتقاد بان
الاوروبيين يجب ان يصبحوا اتباعا في هذا
الملف وان يستقوا اشاراتهم من اجنده
الولايات المتحده ورد الفعل الصينيه
المبالغ فيه على حد وصفه مكروه اكد انه لا
مصلحه للاوروبيين في تسريع ازمه تايوان
ومعنى من باريس مراسل الجزيره محمد
البقالي محمد نعود ونقف معك بخصوص هذه عند
هذه التصريحات رسائله رسائل ماكرون وكيف
تتفاعل كذلك
في الحقيقه وسيله هذه التصريحات او ما
احتوت هذه التصريحات ليس جديدا تماما ولكن
هذه هي المره الاولى التي هي يستعمل فيها
ماكرون هذه الكلمات والتي يقول الامور
فيها بهذا الوضوح وبهذه الطريقه يقول بانه
لا مصلحه لاوروبا في الانجرار وراء ما
سماها التبعيه وقد استعمل هذا المصطلح
وهذا امر جديد وراء الولايات المتحده طرح
سؤالا خلال هذه المقابله الصحفيه وقال هل
من مصلحه الاوروبيين ان يدفعوا او ان
يسرعوا هذه ازمه تايوان وان يذهب وراء
الولايات المتحده في هذا الصراع مع الصين
وقال واجاب بنفسه لا وبالتالي فكانت دعوته
واضحه الى الاوروبيين بعدم الانجرار
الموقف
الرئيسه يبدو انه متاثر باجواء الزياره
لانه يعود الان من الصين ولكنه ايضا متاثر
بحوادث سابقه وبصوابق مع الولايات المتحده
يجب ان نتذكر ان الرئيس
سبق ان دعا الى ما وصفها بالاستقلاليه
الاستراتيجيه لاوروبا على عهد الرئيس
السابق دونالد ترامب لحظتها حين انقطع حبل
الود بين الولايات المتحده وبين الدول
الاوروبيه وصار هناك توتر خاصه في موضوع
الدفاع كان الرئيس الفرنسي يدعو
الاوروبيين الى البحث عن صيغه
لتشكيل قوه دفاع مشترك من هنا كانت
البدايه ثم انها الولايات المتحده
لم تستشير الاوروبيين عند انسحابها من
افغانستان بتلك الطريقه والاوروبيون بشكل
عام والفرنسيون بشكل خاص لم ينظروا بعين
الرضا الى هذا الامر ايضا الفرنسيون اخذوا
على الولايات المتحده مساله الغواصات التي
كانت فرنسا قد وقعت صفقه حجمها قدر عام
2016 بخمسين مليار يورو مع استراليا
لتزويدها بغواصات نوويه فقفزت الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا على هذه الصفقه واخذوها
من فرنسا لحظتها فرنسا ابدت غضبا شديدا
واعلنت بان هذا ليس سلوك الاصدقاء وان هذا
الامر يمثل طعنه في الظهر وبالتالي يمكن
ان نقرا هذا التصريح هو تراكم لمجموعه من
الاحداث التي في الفتره الماضيه وهناك
احساس الفرنسي بان الولايات المتحده لا
يمكن الاعتماد على صداقتها الا ما دام
الامر يخدم مصالحها وبالتالي فكانت هذه
الدعوه بهذه الصيغه وبهذه الكلمات بعض
المصادر الدبلوماسيه التي تحدثنا اليها
قالت ان الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون في
الحقيقه لديه تصور ليقول هذا التصور ان
الاتحاد الاوروبي يجب ان يصبح القوه
الثالثه بعد الولايات المتحده والصين او
بعد الصين والولايات المتحده حسب من سيحتل
الصداره وفرنسا في هذه القوه الثالثه التي
هي الاتحاد الاوروبي سيكون لها مركز
الصداره وبالتالي تصبح عمليا هي القوه
الثالثه في العالم وبالتالي فهو يدفع دفعا
الاوروبيين في اتجاه تشكيل هذه القوه او
تشكيل هذه يصفها بالاستقلاليه
الاستراتيجيه تجاه الولايات المتحده يبقى
الان هل سيستجيب له الاوروبيون ام لا
الواضح ان العلاقات الاوروبيه الامريكيه
هي متجذره وقويه جدا خاصه بعد ذهاب الرئيس
السابق دولار ترامب الذي اذن العلاقات
ومجيء الرئيس الحالي خاصه مع ارتباط
الاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده بحلف
النيتو
22 او 22 دوله من الاتحاد الاوروبي تحت
حلف النيتو الولايات المتحده تمثل هي
قاطره حلف النيتو ولكن يبدو ان هذه
التصريحات سيكون لها ما بعدها وقد تدفع
فعلا في اتجاه ما يصفه البعض هنا بوقف
التبعيه تجاه الولايات المتحده شكرا جزيلا
لكم محمد البقالي مراسلنا من باريس